Hello, I'm Gavin.
I'm Dan.
And we are the Slow Mo Guys.
We always have been
deep down, I would say.
I saw a high-speed flash image online
of a drill spitting paint
in all directions looked really cool.
And being a high-speed flash,
I imagined there was no
video to go alongside it.
So we're gonna to shoot
the Slow Mo video version
of the drill swooping paint in the air.
We've got big drill bit here.
Yeah.
Six different colors of
paint so nice variety.
Nice gradient there.
Gonna glob it all over the drill bit,
spin it round and make a nice pattern.
So we're gonna poke it
through, like a whiteboard
and then see what the pattern looks like.
I've got to make some nice art.
Lovely.
Alright, we'll start
our little process here.
Okay, the first thing to do
is drill a hole through this,
this board, which we can then
That's eight bucks down the drain.
Let's make it a little bigger.
Yeah, that's good.
Really saturate the drill.
Go.
Wow, that was really cool.
That was awesome.
I don't think I did the
drill bit completely.
The drill bit is completely loose.
It looks wicked though.
That looks cool though.
You've gotta put the drill
a little bit properly.
But this whole is covered in paint.
It's through a board, I didn't know,
I thought it was done.
Three, two, one.
Well, I think that looked
damn magnificent to be honest.
Look at that, it does look really cool.
That's some proper art right there.
Damien has to watch out.
Do you think we should sign it?
Yeah, I do.
First bit 20p.
Wanna do it?
Yeah, can you hold this
cause it's a bit like
Nah, you can do it, get a dank in there.
Yeah, put Dan.
I need more paint.
This is my actual signature by the way
in case you are watching this.
Such a knob.
Skip the whole video without
getting paint on me you do that
Absolute Ronald, get it off now.
So thank you very much
for watching that video.
Don't eat the paint.
Sorry, sorry.
I wanted to see what it tastes like
Saw that in the corner of my eyes.
Please follow us on
Twitter if you would like.
Subscribe to the channel,
even buy a shirt their lovely,
and as always, Dan will buy you a drink
if he sees you wearing the shirt.
It's in his contract he
has to do it legally.
It's true.
Yeah it is, for real.
What a genuine annoyance.
You gonna leave that in?
Yeah.